- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here,
and I'm here with Guemmy
Kim, who's a director
of product management at
Google in account security.
And my question for you, Guemmy is
everyone's always talking
about account security.
Why should I or the folks watching care?
- Yes. So it sounds like a technical term,
but it's actually something
that affects us every day.
Think of all of the online
accounts that you use,
whether that's your bank or
Google or any other service.
Well, any of those
accounts actually hold all
of your personal information,
and like a house, you
want it to protect that
personal information that you care about.
There's always gonna be things like bugs,
and rats, and thieves that try to come in.
And so you wanna make
sure that they don't.
- And what's gonna happen,
like, if somehow someone gets
into my account, what's
the worst that they can do?
- Well, I mean, just taking
a Google account for example,
like, not only can they take
your personal information
like your photos, or information
you're sending in Gmail,
you know, they could also get access
to all of your other online accounts.
As you know, you know,
your Gmail account is
actually a key to getting
into your bank, your social
media accounts, your eCommerce,
because once you compromise,
for example, the Gmail account
then I can get into all of
those other accounts as well.
- Yeah, people can steal money from you,
they can misrepresent you,
they can see all your private information,
- Right. Exactly.
It can get to be pretty scary.
So I think this is something
people should pay attention to.
- Mhm.